[Musique]
bonjour françois bayrou bonjour merci de
répondre à mes questions ce matin sur
rmc et bfm tv vous êtes maire de pau
vous êtes président du modem et vous
êtes haut commissaire au plan mais ça
sert à quoi finalement le plan ça sert à
quoi un haut commissaire au plan abbas
est deux à mon sens une des missions les
plus importantes ou savez pendant
des décennies deux ou trois décennies
on a fait de la politique
en regardant
non pas les années qui venaient ni les
décennies qui venait mais le l'immédiat
accident le scandale de la veille le ce
qui entraîne l'émotion vous savez bien
c'est votre métier et donc on s'aperçoit
après que si on ne regarde pas le long
terme alors on se trouve en situation
absolument critique
le jeu nous allons lui on est en
situation dans de nombreux domaines et
bien seulement critiquer bien ceci
justifie absolument la mission qui est
confiée à la petite équipe qui est
chargée de
dégager les enjeux de l'avenir et de les
faire entrer dans le débat national je
prends un exemple qui est ce matin dans
le journal marianne le plan a sorti une
étude extrêmement précises pour savoir
pourquoi la france était dans cette
situation inacceptable catastrophique
d'avoir des déficit du commerce
extérieur par dizaines et dizaines de
milliards ça veut dire qu'on importe
beaucoup plus qu'on exporte 60 70
milliards alors que les allemands sont
en excédent de 250 milliards par exemple
on exporte de la pomme de terre mais on
importe des chips exactement transformer
les produits qu'on ne sait plus
transformer les promesses c'est à dire
nous avons été un très grand pays
industriel et puis peu à peu on a
considéré que au fond
l'intérêt général du pays de la nation
deux étaient moins importants où devait
- diriger les choses que l'intérêt
chaque entreprise en a cru que la somme
des intérêts particuliers faisait
l'intérêt général il se trouve que ce
n'est pas vrai parce que la france peu à
peu se trouvait dépouillé de ses
capacités productives c'est vrai en
agroalimentaire vous l'indiquer en vend
des pommes en import du jus de pomme
enfin des des choses de cette de cet
ordre vous l'avez c'est vrai pour
l'industrie le faire on a calculé pour
la calculer on s'est amusé à calculer le
prix du déficit commercial sur la
ratatouille vous savez la ratatouille à
il ya cinq légumes du poivron de et on
s'aperçoit que l'on à 800 millions
d'euros de déficit sur les produits les
légumes qu'ils font là des produits qui
sont normalement la fierté de la france
mais justement françois bayrou ya hier
vous l'avez peut-être entendu eu cette
affaire autour du pull de l'armée
française sur la question du made in
france et les politiques se sont un peu
tous jetés dans la gueule du loup arnaud
montebourg le premier puis xavier
bertrand marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon sur la question des pulls
français qui serait en réalité
aujourd'hui fabriqué par la chine alors
ça n'était pas juste ça n'explique
formation juste c'est est ce que vous
appelez fenioux c'était en partie faux
parce que quand on regarde dans les
faits les entreprises qui en effet
produisent les pulls français pour
l'armée
il y en a la moitié qui sont produits en
france il y en à l'autre moitié qui sont
produits au maghreb est ce que ça vous
le regrettez
non pour être pour être honnête
si on veut que les entreprises
françaises soient
compétitives comme on dit c'est à dire
qu'elles puissent proposer des prix des
produits à des produits abordables tout
en gardant la conception du produit la
recherche quand il ya de la recherche le
design quand il ya du design le les
points de commercialisation critique il
faut qu'elles puissent le faire à des
prix abordables
lorsque les allemands produisent des
voitures et que ses voitures sont
achetés par tous parce qu'elles sont
réputés de très haute qualité ils ont
produisent la moitié des pièces au moins
sont produites dans les pays de l'est
européen parce que les conditionnant un
travail voitures allemand elles n'en
sont pas moins voitures allemandes ce
qui est crucial pour moi c'est que vous
conserviez le produit parce que quand
vous garder le produit la définition du
produit le regarder à la fois son
présent la production et vous garder son
avenir vous êtes aux commandes
vous pouvez améliorer
constamment mais dans le cas de ces
pulls par non j'en viens à noah notre
histoire de pulls de l'armée française
quand on en revient à ça oui en effet il
se serait égal du loup parce que c'était
une fait qu news comme vous dites et que
non ce n'est pas une entreprise chinoise
qui produit des pulls français mais ce
qu'ils ont eu raison de salaires
d'alerté est ce qu'ils ont eu raison de
dire c'est à nous de produire les pulls
de l'armée française mais de vous dit
deux choses à la fois est-ce qu'ils ont
eu raison de propager des fausses
rumeurs et des informations mensongères
non et c'est une un des maux dont nous
souffrons et on peut pas accepter dans
un débat que dans un débat comme celui
là les protagonistes ceux qui sont au
premier rang de de l'action et du débat
puisse ainsi se faire propagateurs de
fausses nouvelles parce que c'est ça la
vérité ça n'était pas vrai je dis ça
pour ceux qui pour ceux qui nous
écoutent c'était faux un mensonge
deuxièmement est ce que j'attendais plus
de sérieux de la part des candidats à la
présidentielle quoi j'attends d'eux
qu'ils soient véridiques qu'il dise la
vérité
premier point mais deuxième point est ce
qu'on a raison de braquer le projecteur
d'éclairer
chacune des situations qui provoque la
crise dans laquelle nous sommes au
détriment de la france je vais venir
dans une une phrase est ce qu'on a
raison oui on a raison pourquoi parce
que le on devrait avoir croupi en devrez
non on doit avoir comme loi ou en tout
cas je proposerai qu'on la connaît comme
loi on doit être présent sur tous les
secteurs dont nous ne sommes pas exclu
par exemple par manque de matières
premières il ya un très grand secteur
énergétique le les hydrocarbures le
pétrole et le gaz on an'a pas chez nous
on en a plus on en avait eu le gaz chez
nous à lacq
lambert mais pour aujourd'hui il n'y en
a plus donc oui dans tous les secteurs
où nous avons la capacité scientifique
technologique la capacité industrielle
on doit être présent et on doit se fixer
comme objectif d'être présent et c'est
la responsabilité de l'état de brevets
et d'acheter de produire est acheté
nommé jeudi et d'acheter parce que le
code pour le coup des commandes
publiques et très précis là-dessus vous
le savez mieux que personne puisque vous
êtes aussi maire de pau on a la faveur
de cette histoire de pulls j'en reviens
à ça mais parce que c'est à la croisée
de beaucoup de questions on re découvre
au fond que le droit européen nous
empêche d'acheter français c'est à dire
que ça vous êtes si vous êtes une
collectivité vous n'avez pas le droit de
privilégier une entreprise française
plutôt qu'une autre entreprise non je
crois que nous avons toutes les
possibilités
en réfléchissant aux marchés aux
composantes du marché et pour moi
l'emploi est une composante du marché
vous pouvez justifier en disant je
préfère que ce soit local je prenne pas
trop de coûts de transport vous vous
faites en sorte que en effet en prennent
en compte les nuisances qui viennent du
transport en prennent en compte les
nuisances qu'ils viennent fasse appel à
clairvaux nation savez ce qu'on dit pas
clairement favorisé une entreprise
française point barre 2 parce qu'il ya
des lois
qui sont des lois pour une concurrence
équitable juste et pas visibles et
signalés c'est pourquoi
on doit aller dans ce sens là mais
allons un tout petit peu plus loin
puisque nous avons abordé le sujet
qu'est ce qui est en jeu dans cette
affaire là il n'y a pas seulement les
emplois français il y à la totalité du
modèle social français nous avons un
modèle social qui est unique au monde
nulle part dans le monde vous ne
trouverez éducation gratuite santé
gratuite
assurance-chômage garantie retraite
garanti par répartition nous sommes la
seule société au monde qui a choisi
cette solidarité du tous pour un quel
que soit l'accident que vous avez même
si vous êtes pauvres si vous êtes
atteint par une maladie gravissime où il
faut des molécules de rares et des
traitements unique vous êtes en france
garantie de la voir et personne ne le
dit jamais personne n'en parle jamais on
fait tomber en france contrairement aux
on met l'accent ne vous demandera pas
votre carte bleue comme vous entré à
l'hôpital vous êtes soigné parce que
vous êtes vous appartenez à cette
communauté nationale et 7
ce modèle social incroyable unique ce
modèle social éducatif unique salle est
entièrement il est entièrement assis sur
notre capacité à le financer et nous ne
le financerons que si nous avons un
appareil productif qui est à la hauteur
et vous voyez comment ces deux enjeux là
économique et sociale ces deux enjeux là
sont des enjeux cruciaux
pour l'avenir et donc notre notre ligne
directrice en tout cas c'est celle que
nous proposons nous c'est celle de la
reconquête tous ces secteurs que nous
avons laissé tomber alors il est juste
et naturel que nous ayons une stratégie
pour les records et resterez vous
souvenez que l'on fait que j'avais fait
une campagne présidentielle sur ce thème
avec deux verbes qui était produire et
instruire
à l'époque ce n'était peut-être pas
candidat parce que j'aimerais stock ce
n'est pas encore mûr mais peut-être la
nécessité va-t-elle l'imposé aujourd'hui
on va on va y revenir sur cette question
y compris politiques vous parliez à
l'instant de cette enquête en effet fait
par le haut commissariat au plan qui est
révélée par le journal marianne qui nous
dit que si on prend neuf cents produits
de consommation courante eh bien on est
aujourd'hui en déficit commercial
c'est-à-dire qu'on les importe alors
qu'on pourrait parfaitement les produire
et qu'on est très mauvais sur la
transformation jeu prenait l'exemple de
la pomme de terre mon produit des pommes
de terre mais en les exportent et on
importe des chips on produit du bois on
l'exportent mais en importe des
meilleurs à ce trophée comment on fait
comment pour être bon aussi dans la
transformation ça suffit pas de le
montrer comment on fait
stratégie nationale c'est pourquoi il
faut quelque chose on peut le nommer
plan moi je j'aime cette histoire qui
vient de du général de gaulle est de
jean monnet après guerre c'est à dire la
la collectivité nationale communauté
nationale qui dit nous allons ensemble
réunir les conditions et faire naître la
volonté publique et privée parce qu'on
ne le fera pas si c'est seulement le
public parce qu'on n'aura pas les moyens
faut que tout les gars ont on a vous
rendez compte de la situation on a des
entreprises françaises qui sont parmi
les premières du monde ont fabriqué des
satellites moyens on fabrique des des
lanceurs en fabrique avions parmi les
meilleurs de la planète je vais vous
donner un exemple quand même françois
perrault on parlait tout à l'heure de
l'automobile allemande quand on voit que
au moment où on se parle la moitié de
notre secteur automobile en france est à
l'arrêt est à l'arrêt pourquoi parce que
on est dépendante c'est un tout petit
mais costaud processeur ces semi
conducteurs comme on dit que l'on
importe et qu'on a plus en ce moment
alors évidemment pour répondre à ça la
france s'est dit bon on va remettre au
pot on va remettre sur la table et
emmanuel macron nous dit on va mettre 6
milliards 6 milliards sur cinq ans pour
ses semi conducteurs on est tous là haut
à 6 milliards 5 ans est sublime sauf que
dans le même temps en fait on à tsmc qui
est le champion mondial du
semiconducteur qui lui mais
accrochez-vous bien 100 milliards sur
trois ans
on n'est pas dans le game on n'est pas
dans le jeu il y a avec nos petits 6
milliards qui nous parle il ya khouya
une maladie française
je ne voudrais pas que vous en soyez
victime je veux vous préservez vous
protéger de cette balade il ya une
maladie française qui est que en france
on adore voir ce qui ne va pas mais ça
n'aurait pas pu il en al gore mais si on
pouvait l'anticiper si si vous aviez été
nommé haut commissaire en tenant il ya
longtemps si j'ai bien compris si je
peux être même si j'avais été élu quand
j'ai proposé cette stratégie là je vous
dis il ya des moments les choses ne sont
pas mûrs faut avoir l'humilité de le
reconnaître et donc
on pouvait on devait on s'est trompé de
ne pas le faire on a été envahie par une
idéologie souterraine qui est qui était
une idéologie qui qui faisait qu'on
voyait d'un mauvais oeil l'intervention
de l'état on s'est trompé sur toute la
ligne sur ces sujets a mis à mon avis
puisque on a vendu abandonner une partie
de nos secteurs de production mais
arrêtons de penser que nous sommes
incapables de relever les défis je crois
que nous pouvons les relevés tous quand
on a une technologie et une science du
niveau qui est celui de la technologie
et de la science française quand on sait
fabriquer des satellites des fusées
ddd avions des avorteurs de personnes on
a peur de perdre en meute on doit
n'avoir peur de personne à condition que
tout le monde commence à comprendre
qu'on est embarqué sur le même bateau
que l'état a le devoir d'être
visionnaire s'il peut stratège s'il doit
et fédérateur rassembler autour de la
table par exemple les très grands
services de recherche les très grands
secteurs industriels qui eux savent
faire et qui peuvent aider à la
naissance d'entreprises plus jeune des
startups comme vous dites qu'ils
prendront le relais sur ces secteurs-là
et les protéger et les aider parce que
quand vous êtes une très grande
entreprise vous avez un secteur de
distribution dans le monde entier vous
avez des recettes
l'organisation commerciale de
distribution dans le monde entier et
c'est là qu'il faut aller apporter le
soutien des grands aux plus petits et
les aider aussi à l'étranger françois
bayrou ce matin je suis quand même assez
frappé chez vous d'une forme quand même
presque deux à la fois d'impatience à
réussir à faire changer les choses est
un peu de regrets ça quand vous quand
vous me rappeler le slogan qui a été le
vôtre lorsque vous étiez candidat à la
présidentielle quand vous me dites mais
au fond ça aurait pu changer si j'avais
été élu est-ce qu'il est trop tard
est-ce que vous avez renoncé ou est ce
qu'on vous dit au fond basso ce moment
il est encore d'actualité alesi quoi
c'est drôle parce que le l'idée que au
fond on devrait un jour être amené à
renoncer comme vous dites c'est le verbe
que vous avez utilisé ce verbe
n'appartient pas à mon vocabulaire vous
n'avez pas renoncé non à rien je suis
comme vous quelque chose d' extrêmement
précis je suis un citoyen qu'est ce que
c'est un citoyen c'est une personne une
femme un homme un père de famille une
mère de famille un jeune homme ou une
jeune fille qui se sent responsable vous
l'êtes un tout petit piment si je peux
me permettre mangez pas été candidate à
la présidentielle soit bien des portes
quelques citoyens ça viendra peut-être
et donc le
pleinement citoyen ça veut dire
pleinement responsable et je n'ai jamais
de ma vie a aucune minute j'espère que
ça ne viendra pas si ça vient je
viendrai vous le dire mais je n'ai à
aucune minute eu la tentation de
renoncer à une part quelconque de cette
responsabilité mais parmi vos jambes des
gens plus précisément mais françois
bayrou on est à l'aube de cette campagne
présidentielle il y en aura encore
d'autres derrière j'ose parler de votre
âge il est public donc c'est pour ça que
je le dis vous avez le même âge que
michel barnier candidat vous avez huit
ans - que joe biden qui est président
aux états unis il n'y a aucune raison de
renoncer c'est ce que vous vous dites
aussi y compris à être président à
gouverner a dirigé la fraîcheur qui ait
aucune ambiguïté
il ya en france un président de la
république
je pense que de tous ceux que j'ai vus
fréquenté observé depuis
deux ou trois décennies
il est celui qui rase qui a le plus de
capacité à affronter le monde incroyable
dans lequel nous sommes il n'a pas peur
ça compte il a des idées ça compte
il a le cette capacité à faire naître
une énergie y compris dans l'ensemble
européen vous avez vu sa rencontre avec
un gala merkel c'est au fond ce qu'elle
a dit et il a
comment dirais-je le le sens des choses
essentielles et de la différence entre
les choses essentielles et les choses
secondaires donc trouvons rien dit là le
soutenaient e s'il décide de se
représenter ou quand il aura décidé de
se représenter je le soutiendrai
qu'ils le fassent un peu plus rapidement
qu'il ne le fait l'un
c'est ce que nous avons eu plusieurs
fois des présidents de la république qui
en est fait songer à se représenter et
puis vous avez vu que tous ont dit
pendant le temps j'exerce le coeur de
mes fonctions je vais pas aller me
lancer dans une campagne avec lui la
campagne elle commence en soirée à eric
zemmour qui désormais est en capacité de
se retrouver au 2e tour face à lui est
ce que vous vous dites bon est ce qu'il
faudrait pas rentrer dans le débat
rentré dans le combat s qu'eric zemmour
pourrait gagner
une élection tout le monde peut gagner
mais deux
le sujet qui est posé par la candidature
éventuelle d'eric zemmour et par ses
déclarations plus
tonitruante les unes que les autres
c'est un sujet qui n'est pas seulement
politique ou électorale c'est un sujet
pour l'identité de la france
on voit des on lit des choses absolument
bouleversante
quand eric zemmour on connaît tous eric
zemmour depuis longtemps depuis un mois
les tic nos journalistes et moi j'aurais
jamais imaginé que qu'il dérive vers des
thèmes de cet ordre là quand eric
zemmour dit parlant d petite fille juive
assassinée par moi même des rats à
toulouse qui l'a pris par les cheveux et
qu'il a tué d'une balle dans la tête
quand il dit et quand il insinue
qu'elle sont pas vraiment française
parce qu'elles ont été enterrés en
israël
et il les met dans la même phrase que
mairat qui lui a été en enterré dans
dans son pays d'origine au maghreb
est ce qu'on peut imaginer pire comme
déclaration mais quand vous voyez c'est
7% des français je vous avais à voter
pour vous avez des filles expliqué j'ai
des filles
11 on sait ce que c'est l'enfance et
l'enfance massacrée
l'enfance eux
profané par des parts des as tu une
forme de se mettre dans une seconde
profanation de la part de dérégler moins
juteuse jeu je ressens sage le dis comme
comme vous voyez avec eux l'émotion d'un
père de famille comment peut-on dire des
choses comme ça comment peut-on être
politique citoyen
civique se prétendre east rien quand on
dit des choses comme ça mais ça d écoute
très loin dans l'histoire parce que ça
ce type de déclaration qui dit deux
choses au fond vous ne pouvez pas vous
arracher votre origine un prêt comme ça
vous êtes condamnés à vie être dans
votre origine dans votre naissance dans
votre religion vous pouvais pas élargir
votre regard et deuxièmement la france a
devraient être tous pareils tous à la
même toise rien on connaît très très
bien ça c'est la saint barthélémy
quand on n'a pas voulu qui est
des protestants avec les mêmes droits
que les catholiques c'est la révocation
de l'édit de nantes
et chaque fois parce que il connaît il
sait très bien zemmour ce que je dis là
chaque fois il a justifié le pire non
justifiés ja le centenaire de ce pire là
un pays ne peut pas se relever aucun
pays dans le monde aucun pays dans le
monde sans exception n'a pu se relever
de cette espèce de 2,2 glissement
perpétuel vers les cheveux tu râlais
réelles et très grave et vous avez des
mots très grave et même les yeux émus en
le disant françois bayrou haut
commissaire au plan maire de pau
président du modem merci d'avoir répondu
à mes questions ce matin